what up reject nation Greg outta here
John
so as we're filming this we are prepping
to leave for Mexico meaning as this
videos up we are probably in Mexico but
we wanted to do this video because it
sounded like fun we could use a laugh
right now not laugh let's find out let's
find out so patreon we do full-length TV
show reactions and weekly Q&A is the
main things plus a bunch of other stuff
as well but one of the reward tiers is
whatever video you request we must
definitely do and it's it was a reaction
and today's reaction is gonna be for
ant-man unnecessary censorship try not
to laugh boy this comes from tyler hague
tyler hague lives all the way in
wisconsin and all that which is my
Boston accent sky Anson Wisconsin wants
in hey I don't know it doesn't matter so
it was all the way in Wisconsin and oh
my god we must move on the last time we
saw him he looks kind of like you know
the guy in Terminator 2 who Arnold stole
the clothes from at the beginning mix
with Tim Allen and the Santa Claus when
he starts growing a beard he looks you
put those two together he looks like
that guy so he is one
intimidating-looking mofo but with the
personality of what would you say I got
the looks down you do the personality Oh
with the personality of you know someone
who's just really friendly and mellow
yeah he's kind of like happier more
upbeat version of Winnie the Pooh yeah
we love you Tyler hey Tyler
it's videos just for you just for you
only for you in fact if you're not Tyler
you're watching this stop stop uno dos
God Ninja Panda I will he did the
adventure you Janet with such ferocity
my wife again
and I'll show you ferocity long time now
soon
how's retirement your face
thank you okay welcome to baskin-robbins
would you like to try our mango blast I
see in the back teeth pronto no
baskin-robbins always finds out I'm
sorry no me just to be totally off the
books I'll just pretend I didn't see it
even standing there watching me this
whole time yes I assume that you've
already my daughter hope I did she's
great I go to all this effort to let you
my men hope as you arrested okay we can
try this and when he fails I'll do it
myself
how do you make them do that and sky
objects 50 times their weight and use
electromagnetic waves stimulate that I I
can do anywhere here anything and
everything Darren cross he's gonna
release chaos world
I think our first move should be the
Avengers now are you ready all those
years ago you what did you see I saw
myself it's not too long you place and
they get welcome back you know that he
was arrested for a smoothie machine
right - smoothie machines you know the
Austrian is actually from despising
YouTube almost you really should write
poetry
alright guys I'm in position you tried
to hi good for me and now it's gonna
blow up in your face
you know I came to the house the other
night but you were there you see you
just put the gun yeah yeah what you're
doing was surprised myself I have to get
somewhere I'll see you later hanging
really hope what's got us quick today
really looking for this dude there's no
one seen with a clashing distress attack
we'll start lighting power moves right
well you got well we got everything
nowadays we got a guy who jumps in we
got a guy who we got a guy who crawls up
the wall you gotta be more specific I'm
looking for a guy that and I'm like dear
maybe it's time we
I wasn't ready but I think I know I
think I did okay on my first try not to
laugh challenge this was a year first
it's the first one that will go up on
YouTube now I just want to go back
through ant-man and see if all of those
words were actual F words or if they
added an F sound right before the bleep
sound and sky objects 50 times there's a
lot of places where clearly yeah it's
supposed to be the word I was thinking
that too where I'm like it sounds like
they're saying the F word and I'm gonna
f word would have fit into that sentence
because they can't all just be fight you
know yeah yeah there were some moments
here though that because you just get
treated to this alternate universe where
a man is just a movie about a bunch of
horny penis we're all getting into
conflicts because they're all having sex
with each other and having so silly like
it's it's kind of a repetitive joke but
it tickled me so much I see them all so
serious it's just it changes the whole
plot yeah yeah if Hollywood made the
ant-man porno I I'd liked The Avengers 1
and I thought the Avengers Marty Lee had
bigger laughs maybe because I was also
more surprised by it well he's me yeah
he has me twice and there's a wider
variety of scenes and moments you could
play with this felt like there was some
kind of cohesive story erotic tension
between the Scott Lang but then also
hang Tim's got this even alternate life
where he's Corey Stoll - yeah and like I
don't know it's like closer meets
ant-man yeah yeah yeah and Paul Rudd's
gonna have sex with all the ants - like
that's the that's the secret power the
secret gift is you know come a sex
feels like a weird indie erotic drama
I can't wait for like a hundred years to
go by and for Marvel to start exploring
that junk crossover I mean this is kind
of hard to put together I mean I imagine
for a ninja Pandy has to sit through the
whole movie I'm sure there's a lot of
moments that he doesn't actually use I'm
sure there's a lot of let me try this
movie now and tried this line out
because you're not going off memory for
this you got it like put the whole movie
in and then try to make as many of the
scenes actually work and then summer
might not be as funny so you gotta take
that out so imagine this is actually a
pretty long editing process like it's a
simple task but a time-consuming task
because you gotta really be able to
determine which ones really would work
it and I find it more clever when it's
stuff like might be you tried to hide
your for me let's got us quick today I
go to all this effort to let you see my
the wrong hope yeah when it becomes
anything other than me yeah it starts to
become more creative because yeah I mean
like for four minutes worth you've also
got to think like how many of these
moments are gonna play well in a
sequence together yeah exactly
you know tight compact a lot of fun good
job the other two is I appreciated a
sense of comic timing where they would
hold little punch lines or little aside
lines to add yeah text to the new
context a creative daddy yeah I am
sweetheart this guy actually knows door
girls mushroom is an imaginary guy day
it's a whole team 100 oak is one kx1 you
take first half of back to because for
people we go
and then the smoothie thing in the movie
is not a call back like when he says
he's stole two smoothie machines I
actually I don't remember that to call
back but it plays like a reoccurring
joke call back about having sex with a
smoothie yeah the books off the records
but if you want to one of those mango
blasts on your way out the door I'll
just pretend I didn't see it the mango
blast thing or what I call it starts to
feel like it's related to that yeah
Michael Pena
that way in some ways this worked better
and this is try not to laughter over
time so I was really actually trying
very hard the other one I kind of gave
up on that's what I'm like no I'm not
gonna break but there's some really hard
times
I always appreciate when they're more
than just a medley and they start to
kind of reveal a through-line right
right well thank you ninja panda for in
this awesome video I'm hitting the
notification I'm subscribed but I'm
hitting the notification well for you
guys got more of his as I'm sure we'll
be getting more requests for wonder how
long this gimmick will make me laugh
because in some ways I can't watch one
of these every day but periodically I
don't think it'll lose its charm any
time soon you guys can subscribe to
ninja pan to subscribe to the reject
nation please and that notification bill
for us to check us on patreon we got
full a TV show reactions weekly Q&A and
here Tyler Hague for being you
appreciate